Die nächsten drei Tage
sind das hier:
Blackbox.
Ich habe etwas Angst davor,
was mich da drin erwarten könnte,
aber ich öffne ihn trotzdem -
den Hinweis.
Mona Vetsch hat wieder einmal
keine Ahnung, wo es hingeht.
Eine schöne Küchenschürze.
Und der zweite Hinweis:
Wir müssen nach Luzern.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Was ist das?
Es sieht aus wie ...
Eine Schule?
Die Person hält sich ein Blatt
Papier vors Gesicht,
will nicht erkannt werden.
Etwas Semilegales?
Luzern - wir kommen. Los geht's!
Wir reisen nach Luzern.
Das Einzige, was Mona weiss, ist,
dass sie dort Bus Nr. 4 nehmen muss
bis Haltestelle Tiefe.
Ich bin hier
wie ein Cheftourist unterwegs.
Keine Ahnung!
Grüezi, können Sie mir helfen?
- Na, klar.
Ich suche Bus Nr. 4.
Ja, der ist gleich hier.
Sie können gleich einsteigen.
Kennen Sie ...
- Sehr gut: die Gassenküche.
Was ist das?
- Das ist die Gassenküche.
Sie können Bus Nr. 4 nehmen und
bei Haltestelle Tiefe aussteigen.
Dann müssen Sie
noch ein paar Schritte gehen.
Für wen kocht die Gassenküche?
Für die Drogenabhängigen,
die dort ein Mittagessen erhalten.
Dort kümmert man sich um sie.
Dorthin gehe ich für drei Tage.
Ich habe die Schürze schon dabei.
Kochen gehört
nicht zu Monas Kernkompetenzen,
aber sie hat gerade andere Sorgen.
Die zwei Gestalten da vorne
gehen in dieselbe Richtung.
Die werden wohl auch
zur Klientel gehören.
Ja, ich schätze, das könnten
drei schwierige Tage werden.
Wie geht Mona mit Leuten um,
um die man sonst
eher einen Bogen macht?
Und wie viel Freude haben
die Leute hier an einem Kamerateam?
Morgen!
- Guten Morgen.
Mona.
- Yannick.
Ich muss mich hier melden.
Ich habe diesen Hinweis erhalten.
Bin ich hier richtig?
Kommen Sie mit, dann gehen wir
zur Leiterin des Zentrums.
Drei Tage zusammen mit Suchtkranken.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Mona Vetsch.
- Ich bin Franziska.
Bist du mein Empfangskomitee?
Sozusagen.
- Um mich etwas abzufedern.
Genau: Herzlich willkommen hier,
in der Gassenküche,
Kontakt- und Anlaufstelle.
Wir sind ein Betrieb
des Vereins kirchliche Gassenarbeit.
Du wirst die nächsten drei Tage
die verschiedenen Betriebe
des Vereins kennenlernen.
Heute bist du hier.
- In der Gassenküche.
(Mann) Ja.
- (Frau) Schatzi, nein, ist egal!
(Frau) Ich darf ja!
Sorry!
Einfach so tun, als wäre
nichts gewesen. - Genau.
Oh, la la! Hallo, miteinander.
Die Abmachung ist:
Die Leute sollen sich
ganz normal verhalten.
Diejenigen, die nicht im Fernsehen
erscheinen wollen,
werden anonymisiert.
Ich bin eingeteilt,
um in der Küche zu helfen.
Hallo.
Mona, das ist Andi.
Er erwartet dich schon.
Erwartest du mich zum Küchendienst?
Grüezi, Mona, ich bin Andi.
Hallo, das freut mich.
Kochst du heute mit mir?
Jawohl, also du mit mir.
Das ist doch gut.
Du darfst dir
gern eine Schürze anziehen.
Du hast eine bessere Schürze.
Andi ist
ein Besucher der Gassenküche
und langjähriger Drogenkonsument.
Heute hilft er kochen
und verdient so etwas Geld.
Okay. Seit wann konsumierst du denn?
Seit ich 19 Jahre alt bin.
Seit 19. Und warum?
Das ist eigentlich eine blöde Frage.
Mit etwa 16 begann ich zu kiffen.
Einmal probierte ich Kokain.
Später probierte ich auch Heroin.
So schnell bist du drin.
Einfach so probiert man das
nicht aus, oder doch?
Mir hat bis jetzt noch nie jemand
einfach so Heroin angeboten.
Das kann ich dir schon anbieten.
Nein,
du musst es mir nicht anbieten.
Man ist doch
in einer gewissen Szene?
Unsere Clique
probierte das zusammen aus.
Und am Schluss
waren wir alle süchtig.
Er habe aus Neugier
Drogen probiert, sagt Andi.
30 Jahre später,
nach zig Entzugsversuchen
und sogar einer Zeit im Gefängnis,
ist Andi immer noch abhängig.
Zwar nicht mehr von Heroin,
er ist im Methadon-Programm,
aber er nimmt noch Kokain.
Über der Gassenküche
seine Konsumationsräume,
wo man unter Aufsicht
Drogen nehmen könne, sagt er.
Die zeige er mir später noch.
Wo ist der Kompost?
Der ist draussen.
Soll ich das rasch rausbringen?
- Ich zeige dir, wo er ist.
Dann kannst du
das nächste Mal alleine gehen.
Genau, dafür bin ich hier.
Wir müssen nicht zu zweit
zum Kompost raus.
Ich zeige ihn dir jetzt einfach.
- Ja, ist gut.
Wir haben immer ...
Der Kübel, der so gedreht ist,
ist entweder voll oder leer.
D.h., man muss es jetzt
in diesen schütten.
Also, hier draussen stehen sie.
Ist das dort die Raucherecke?
Oder was ist das?
Dort wird gedealt.
Dort draussen wird gedealt?
- Ja, es ist einfach ...
Dürfen die das?
- Ja.
Es wird geduldet. Aber konsumieren
darf man dort nicht.
Ja, aha, aha.
Das Mittagessen
ist also nicht das Einzige,
was die Leute hier holen kommen.
Oh, meine liebe Mona, diese
Salatblätter sind viel zu gross.
Mundgerecht.
- Mundgerecht?
* Mona lacht. *
Du bist ein harter Chef:
also, mundgerechte Stücke.
Ich bin kein harter Chef.
- Du bist Realist.
Genau, deshalb sagte ich, dass die
Salatblätter etwas zu gross seien.
Sorry. Aber aus Fehlern lernt man.
Jeden Tag, Montag bis Sonntag, gibt
es in der Gassenküche Mittagessen.
Das Essen ist nicht gratis,
es kostet 5 Fr.
Susi, willst du von allem?
- Ja, eine kleine Portion.
So?
- Ja.
Etwas mehr Rüebli?
Warum isst du so wenig?
Sie päppeln mich auf,
am Anfang ass ich noch viel weniger.
Dank ihnen
esse ich jetzt wieder mehr.
Jetzt geht es mir
beim Essen sehr gut.
Ich will keinen Broccoli.
Nicht alle hier haben
ein Problem mit Drogen oder Alkohol.
Ein Teil ist von Armut betroffen
und kommt deshalb zum Essen hierher.
Nicht jeder kann herkommen,
sondern man muss sich registrieren.
Wer nicht in der Region wohnt
oder minderjährig ist,
erhält keinen Zugang.
450 Leute aus der gesamten
Innerschweiz verkehren hier.
Was nimmst du noch?
- Ein Dessert.
Gibt es das auch noch?
- Das ist sein Dessert.
Das ist viel schöner.
Was ist denn das jetzt wieder?
Erst jetzt kapiere ich,
was er mit "Dessert" meint:
Drogen rauchen.
Und darauf freut er sich dermassen?
Ich versuche, zu verstehen,
weisst du.
Warum lebt man so?
Wie lebt man so?
Ist das für dich okay?
Vielleicht bin ich bloss zu feige,
um Selbstmord zu begehen.
Ich nahm keine Drogen, als alle
meine Kollegen schon konsumierten.
Ich kiffte bloss.
Aber als mich
meine Freundin verliess,
dachte ich mir:
"Jetzt ist eh alles egal."
Damals bog ich falsch ab.
- Ja.
Aber eben:
Es ist nicht für die Ewigkeit.
Hoffe ich jedenfalls.
Denkst du noch immer,
dass irgendwann ...
Ich denke immer positiv:
Eine Türe wird sich öffnen.
Ich hoffe es für dich.
Und Gott liebt mich.
Er kümmert sich um mich.
Und du kümmerst dich auch um dich
selbst? Das gehört auch dazu.
Gott allein wird es nicht richten.
- Nein, das ist mir schon klar.
Ja, he: Forza!
Ja, Kopf hoch! He, du hast Pause.
- Ja, ich habe Pause.
Die Arbeit in der Küche ist beendet.
Auch Andi hat Pause,
jetzt will er mich mit hoch nehmen.
Du kannst auch mitgehen.
- Was ist denn dort oben?
Oben befinden sich
die Konsumationsräume.
Aber keine Konsumationspflicht?
- Nein.
Also, dann will ich mir das ansehen.
Ich begleite dich.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Du, wir schauen mal. Sag uns, wenn
wir die Kamera ausschalten sollen.
He, mach mal auf! So,
jetzt hat es geklappt. Komm!
Das ist der Konsumationsraum.
(Mann) Hier drin
ist Filmen nicht erlaubt.
Sie filmen nur mich. Mona, komm!
Lasst euch nicht stören.
Es ist alles gut.
Es ist schwierig, weil sie sich
extrem gestört fühlt.
Andi, sollen wir
nicht besser aufhören zu filmen?
Wir stressen die anderen etwas.
Aber Andi will jetzt
erst sein Kokain rauchen.
Ich glaube, wir brechen den Dreh ab,
weil er ein Problem damit hat.
Ihr geht also raus,
ich bleibe noch kurz hier.
Ist gut?
Die aggressive Stimmung
beruhigt sich wieder.
Und wie wir da so sitzen,
erzählt Andi
plötzlich sehr Persönliches.
Der Raucherraum wird von den Dro-
genkonsumenten am meisten genutzt.
Es gibt aber auch Orte, wo man
schnupfen oder spritzen kann.
Und ja: Es verstört mich ziemlich,
wie da rund um mich herum
Leute harte Drogen konsumieren.
Aber lieber hier
als in der Öffentlichkeit
wie zu Platzspitz-Zeiten, denke ich.
Für die Süchtigen
bedeutet dieser geschützte Rahmen,
mehr Hygiene und weniger Stress.
Und für uns als Gesellschaft,
dass wir damit
weniger in Kontakt kommen.
Beim Runtergehen
spricht mich jemand an.
Er fragt mich,
wie ich den Raum oben erlebt habe.
Und, wie hattet ihr es oben?
Du, die einen waren sehr easy,
während die anderen
ziemlich aggressiv wurden.
Das ist normal. Das ist
wegen der illegalen Substanzen.
Auch andere Leute
rund um die Gassenküche
führen sich so auf,
das ist einfach so.
Ich habe eben überhaupt
keine Erfahrung mit Leuten,
die Drogen nehmen:
Bist du jetzt drauf?
Ja, ich bin drauf, aber nicht so,
dass ich rumhängen würde.
Ich bin so drauf,
dass ich nicht auf Entzug komme.
Aber woran merke ich,
dass du drauf bist?
Das merkt man nicht.
Nur wenn man richtig drauf ist,
merkt man es.
Aber darf ich dich etwas fragen?
Es gibt Leute, die sagen:
"Wer drauf ist, wer Junkie ist, ..."
Weisst du, Junkie bedeutet dreckig.
- Sicher?
Bedeutet es nicht Abfall?
- Nein, es bedeutet dreckig.
Ja, man nennt jemanden einen Junkie,
der blutige Hosen
und ein blutiges T-Shirt trägt.
Das ist ein Junkie.
- Bist du kein Junkie?
Ich bin ein Konsument, sozusagen.
Ich konsumiere, achte aber doch noch
etwas auf mein Aussehen.
Aber sind Leute wie du ...
Aber seid ihr selbst
schuld, dass ihr Drogen nehmt?
Ich gebe niemandem die Schuld
ausser mir.
Meine Mutter ist meinetwegen
einige Male im Spital gelandet.
Weil sie sich Sorgen um dich machte?
Sie sagte:
"Ich war keine gute Mutter."
Dabei war meine Mutter
gar nicht schuld.
Ich bin selbst schuld.
Also, hey, ich will dich
nicht länger aufhalten.
Mona.
- Tschau!
Du bist?
- Ich bin Corrado.
Die Gassenküche ist für ein
paar Menschen wie ein Zuhause.
Sie sind jeden Tag hier. Jeden.
* Sentimentale Klavierklänge *
Ein Leben - bestimmt von den Drogen.
Schon nach einem Tag hier
höre ich auf,
alle nach dem Warum zu fragen.
Wahrscheinlich kann man Sucht
nie ganz verstehen,
wenn man selbst nicht süchtig ist.
Um 16.30 Uhr
schliesst die Gassenküche.
Die Leute verstreuen sich
in der Stadt Luzern und Umgebung.
Die Allermeisten haben eine Wohnung
oder irgendwo wenigstens ein Zimmer,
in dem sie unterkommen.
Nach gestern ist mein Blick
auf die Welt bereits ein anderer.
Bei Stoff denke ich
nicht mehr zuerst an Textilien.
Und während ich vorher eher
einen Bogen darum gemacht hätte,
steuere ich jetzt voll darauf zu.
Andi sagte, dass er morgens
immer dort vorne sei.
Ich will nachsehen,
ob er schon da ist.
Morgen! Hallo, Andi, wie geht's?
Gut.
- Mona.
Freut mich.
- Hallo, Hans.
* Sie lachen unverständlich. *
Ui, ist das schön.
Jetzt bin ich mit Frau Vetsch
im Fernsehen. Geile Sache!
Und was machst du morgens hier?
Ein Bier saufen.
- Am Morgen schon?
Ja, ich habe Ferien.
- Aha.
Für Hans und Andi
ist der Treff vor dem Laden
nicht der erste Termin des Tages.
Sie waren frühmorgens
schon im Drop-in,
der kontrollierten Drogenabgabe.
Wieso kommt ihr morgens hierher?
Um 8 Uhr
gehen wir jeweils ins Drop-in,
um dort das Methadon abzuholen.
Drop-in? Das ist der Ort, wo ihr ...
- Substitution.
Manche haben ...
Was hast du? Hast du Heroinprobleme?
Nein, ich erhalte SevreLong.
Das ist ... - Wofür denn?
SevreLong ist ein Morphiumderivat.
- Ersatz für Heroin.
Das ist wie Methadon.
Ist das eine Tablette?
- Nein, eine Kapsel.
Müsst ihr immer frühmorgens dorthin?
Ja, weil es 7.45 Uhr öffnet.
- Aha.
Dann gehe ich 7.45 oder 8 Uhr dort
vorbei und komme nachher hierher.
Und wenn dann Zeit für die Küche
ist, gehen wir in die Gassenküche.
Hier spielen
zwei Institutionen zusammen.
Die psychiatrischen Dienste
geben Ersatzdrogen ab,
z.B. Methadon.
Und der Verein Kirchliche
Gassenarbeit bietet einen Ort,
wo die Suchtkranken
tagsüber hingehen können.
Um 9.30 Uhr öffnen die Gassenküche
und die Räume zum Konsumieren.
Im Hinterhof
findet der Kleindeal statt:
Nur so viel,
wie man zum Konsum braucht -
geduldet von der Polizei
und streng überwacht
von der hauseigenen Security.
Wer oben konsumieren will,
muss eine Nummer ziehen.
Dann hat er 25 Min. Zeit.
Wer nur schon
ein paar Sekunden überzieht,
bekommt ein Tagesverbot.
Hier sind auch junge Leute:
Mütter, Väter,
Menschen mit einem normalen Job.
Sie wollen verständlicherweise
nicht, dass man sie filmt.
Nur langjährigen Konsumenten
wie Otti
haben nichts gegen die Kamera.
Mit ihm besuche ich den
sog. IV-Raum, wo man spritzen darf.
Nimm Platz, wo du willst,
wo du immer sitzt, genau.
Hier ist immer jemand dabei.
Die ausgebildete Pflegefachfrau
Sandra Mura hat heute Dienst.
Genau, sie kommen rein ...
Du hast gesehen,
hier sind maximal sechs Plätze.
Häufig ist es recht voll hier.
Sie waschen sich die Hände, dann
geben wir den Löffel ab. Voila!
Und ... Aber ... Ihr bringt
die Substanzen selbst mit?
Ja, sicher.
Das müssen sie selbst
irgendwo organisieren.
Otti ist im Diaphin-Programm,
das ist synthetisch
hergestelltes Heroin.
Trotz der Ersatzdroge
kommt er einmal täglich hierher.
Er ist eine Ausnahme.
Die Allermeisten
im kontrollierten Drogenprogramm
kommen nicht mehr
zur Kontakt- und Anlaufstelle.
Was spritzt du dir?
- Kokain.
Das ist ein 20-Fr.-Brieflein.
Das reicht für einen Tag,
wenn es gut ist. - Ja.
Zu Hause oder am Abend
mache ich das nicht.
Wenn ich alleine bin,
bringt es nichts.
So wird das Blut gestaut.
Dann kann man
die Spritze so ansetzen.
So.
Zuerst sollte
noch etwas Blut kommen.
So.
Wie fühlt sich das jetzt an?
Es kommt langsam.
Ich habe jeweils
ein Rauschen im Ohr.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja.
Bingo!
Jetzt sollte ich
die Spritze herausziehen.
Hoffentlich blutet es nicht
zu stark, das wäre Scheisse.
Dann läuft's an mir runter.
Jetzt den Tupfer, tipptopp.
Es haut mich jetzt also nicht um.
Das Einfahren steigert sich,
weisst du.
Schau, wie ich nachher
zu plappern beginne.
Merkt man dir das an?
Ja.
Sonst bin ich
eine Schlaftablette, weisst du.
Deshalb nehme ich Kokain,
damit ich etwas wache werde.
Aber ein Leben ohne ... Drogen,
ohne dieses Grundgefühl,
kannst du dir nicht vorstellen?
Nein. Ohne Kokain aber schon.
Aber Heroin ist meine Droge,
weisst du.
Das gibt mir die Wärme, die
mütterliche Wärme, die einem fehlt.
Man sieht die Welt etwas schöner,
etwas runder und so.
Otti kommt mir recht verloren vor.
Das war schön.
Es war schön, mit dir zu plaudern.
Alles Gute, Otti.
- Ja, dir auch.
Wenn du noch Fragen hast:
Ich bin every day hier.
Every day. Jeden Tag Drogen.
Vielleicht auch, um zu vergessen,
was die Sucht
aus seinem Leben gemacht hat.
Mir ist nicht ganz klar,
warum du dabei sein musst.
Die können das ja ...
- Ja, man könnte meinen,
sie könnten das rein theoretisch
selbst machen, sich bedienen
aber es kommt immer wieder
zu einer Überdosierung.
Wenn jemand etwas spritzt, zu
viel Heroin oder Kokain spritzt,
dann werden die Leute bewusstlos.
Dann musst du den Notfall ...
- Genau.
Das haut mich um.
Gewisse sagen: "Geiler Stoff,
fährt wirklich super ein."
Da denke ich bei mir:
"Aber also."
Das siehst du nicht jeden Tag.
Ich habe noch nie gesehen,
wie sich jemand einen Schuss setzt.
Wie ist das, wenn du hier Leuten
begegnest, von denen du denkst:
"Das ist dermassen schlimm,
denen müsste man helfen können."
Am Anfang dachte ich noch oft so,
v.a. bei jungen Leuten:
"Du hast eine Lehre gemacht,
hast Familie usw."
"Du hast auch ein soziales Netz."
"Warum bist du jeden Tag hier?" Das
hat mich anfangs recht mitgenommen.
Aber inzwischen ist es so,
dass meine Einstellung ist:
Man kann die Leute
nicht gesund machen
oder heilen von dieser Drogensucht.
Es gibt Leute, die werden
ihr ganzes Leben davon begleitet.
Unser Auftrag ist,
dass sie wenigstens unter sauberen
Bedingungen konsumieren können.
So sehe ich unseren Auftrag.
Der Auftrag ist
nicht primär Abstinenz,
sondern dass Suchtkranke
ein geregeltes Leben führen können.
Wir als Gesellschaft
können ihnen die Sucht nicht nehmen,
aber die Würde zurückgeben.
Ich möchte eine Kerze anzünden
für eine Kollegin, die sich schon
seit Jahren mit der Sucht quält.
Der Verein Kirchliche Gassenarbeit
hilft mit verschiedenen Angeboten
auch ausserhalb der Gassenküche.
Ein Seelsorger bietet Hand, wenn
jemand menschlichen Halt braucht.
Eine Sozialberatung
hilft Suchtkranken,
ihr Leben und v.a. ihre Finanzen
wieder in den Griff zu bekommen.
Das ist aber gut, super.
Okay, dann müssen wir...
Ich habe den neuen Kontoauszug hier.
Und dann gibt es noch das
Paradiesgässli, etwas Einmaliges.
In diesem Haus
werden Familien unterstützt,
die von Sucht oder Armut
betroffen sind.
Das ist ein Ort,
wo Kinder spielen können,
wo Schüler Aufgabenhilfe erhalten
und wo alle gemeinsam
zu Mittag essen können.
Das Paradiesgässli
ist für viele Familien
ein sicherer Hafen
in stürmischen Zeiten.
All diese Angebote der Gassenarbeit
werden zur Hälfte durch
die öffentliche Hand finanziert,
und zum anderen
durch Spenden und kirchliche Gelder.
So auch
die aufsuchende Gassenarbeit.
Für diejenigen,
die gerade abstürzen
oder selbst keine Hilfe suchen.
Die Sozialarbeiterinnen
Nathalie Gloor und Marlies Gessler
sind seit Jahren
auf der Gasse unterwegs.
Die Fixer von früher
sieht man kaum mehr.
Ja, das ist so.
- Die sind verschwunden.
Das ist auch unser Auftrag.
- Es zum Verschwinden bringen.
Aber solche Menschen
gibt es doch noch?
Ja, aber die Bevölkerung denkt,
es gäbe sie nicht mehr
oder immer weniger,
was auch nicht stimmt.
Aber dann haben wir
unseren Auftrag erfüllt.
Der Platz vor dem Bahnhof Luzern
ist einer der wenigen Orte,
wo noch eine kleine Szene
zusammenkommt.
Hier dürfen wir
nicht von Nahem filmen.
Hallo zusammen.
Hier sehe ich Leute, die nicht
in der Gassenküche auftauchen,
z.B. zwei sehr junge Frauen,
beide süchtig und obdachlos.
Und wir erfahren Tragisches.
Wie geht es?
- Gut. Und dir?
Traurig.
- Warum bist du traurig?
Weil jemand gestorben ist.
- Wann? Heute?
Ja, heute. Er hat sich erhängt.
Scheisse.
45. Weiss du, wer?
Ich weiss, wer. Er war bei mir
in der Einkommensverwaltung.
Das tut mir leid.
Wir werden es weiterleiten.
- Ja, jetzt wisst ihr's.
Ein Klient, den beide gekannt haben,
hat sich das Leben genommen.
Dem müssen wir nachgehen.
Wir werden unserem Seelsorger
Meldung machen.
Er wird das offiziell abklären.
Wir klären über die Stadt ab,
ob das wirklich stimmt.
Aber so, wie er es erzählt hat,
wird das stimmen.
Passiert das noch oft bei Leuten,
die so im Elend sind?
Im Schnitt haben wir
etwa zehn Todesfälle im Jahr.
Ja, und dieses Jahr
waren es bereits relativ viele.
Ja.
Überdosis oder Organversagen,
es gibt verschiedene Gründe.
Ich fand ziemlich krass, wie
viele junge Frauen darunter sind,
denen es wirklich sehr elend geht.
- Sehr schlecht, genau.
Leben die zwei, mit denen du
geredet hast, auf der Strasse?
Ja, sie sind beide obdachlos,
nirgendwo gemeldet.
Ich treffe sie nur hier an, also ...
Kommen sie nicht zu euch?
- Sie sind nicht registriert.
Sie kommen zwar vorbei,
wollen sich aber nicht registrieren.
Ist die Situation
für süchtige Frauen
schwieriger als für süchtige Männer?
Ja, ganz sicher, weil sich
diese Frauen prostituieren müssen.
Oder sie müssen stehlen.
In Luzern gibt es
also auch einen Drogenstrich?
Ja, das gibt es.
Häufig ist es nicht der Drogenstrich
gegen Geld, sondern gegen Stoff.
Deshalb findet das oft
bei ihrem Dealer zu Hause statt.
Oder es gibt Männer, die sagen:
"Du kannst als Obdachlose
schon bei mir übernachten,
musst aber den Preis bezahlen.
Gratis gibt es nichts."
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Beim Weggehen sagt mir Marlies,
nach 15 Jahren unterwegs
auf der Gasse, wisse sie eines:
Bei Schwersüchtigen kommen
die Drogen immer an erster Stelle,
vor den Freunden,
vor der Familie, vor den Kindern
und schliesslich sogar
vor dem eigenen Leben.
* Sentimentale Klavierklänge *
Der nächste Morgen ist ein Tag,
wie es ihn nur dreimal im Jahr gibt.
Die "Luzerner Gassenzeitung"
kommt heraus.
Sie hat eine stolze Auflage
von 11'000 Exemplaren.
Andi kauft sich einen Stapel,
um sie zu verkaufen.
43 Fr.
- Ja.
Tschau, Robin.
- Tschau, viel Glück.
Dir auch.
Wir sind sicher die Ersten.
"Luzerner Gassenzeitung"!
Es ist grün.
Andi ist im Stress, damit niemand
anders seinen Verkaufsplatz besetzt.
Es sei der beste in ganz Luzern,
sagt er.
Dann verkaufe ich hier.
"Luzerner Gassenzeitung", Madame.
"Luzerner Gassenzeitung"!
Ach, wie süss!
Lu...
Da brauche ich gar nicht zu fragen.
Braucht es nicht Mut,
alle anzuquatschen?
Grüezi, wollen Sie eine
"Gassenzeitung" kaufen? Nein?
Vielleicht sehe ich zu wenig ...
Verstehst du mich jetzt,
wenn die Leute so Bäh sagen?
Nervt dich das?
- Ja, dich nicht?
Ja, sie lassen dich abblitzen,
ein unangenehmes Gefühl.
So quasi: ein Mensch zweiter Klasse.
Denkst du, es ist das:
Mensch zweiter Klasse?
Ja, einfach: Verdammter Junkie,
was will der hier?
Dann haben sie auch noch Angst,
das Portemonnaie zu zücken.
"Luzerner Gassenzeitung"!
Madame, Sie eine "Gassenzeitung"?
- Grüezi.
Wie viel kostet sie?
- 2 Fr., weil Sie es sind.
Das war ein Spässchen.
Was denken Sie über Leute, die
süchtig sind, die Drogen nehmen?
Es ist schlimm.
- Andi, ist es schlimm?
Schlimm - das kommt immer darauf an.
Trinken Sie ab und zu auch Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder, aber nicht viel.
Wenn man eine Stange Bier pro Tag
trinkt, geht das.
Aber wenn es dann mehr wird ...
Oder frühmorgens schon ...
Ja, frühmorgens.
Andi schaut sofort auf sein Bier.
Erwischt! Ich danke Ihnen vielmals.
Andi zahlte pro Zeitung 1 Fr.
und verkauft sie für 2 Fr. weiter.
Von manchen Leuten
erhält er sogar mehr.
Danke vielmals. Auf Wiedersehen.
Was machst du jetzt mit dem Geld?
Worin investierst du?
In einen neuen Fernseher.
- Einen neuen Fernseher?
Gibt es auch Zeitungsverkäufer,
die sich das Geld nehmen
und sich einfach irgendwie
den nächsten Schuss kaufen?
Ja, ja.
- Ja, nicht?
Aber kann ich ihm dann
mit gutem Gewissen 10 Fr. geben,
wenn ich weiss,
dass er damit Drogen kauft?
Er tut ja etwas dafür.
Ich weiss es doch nicht.
Mit gutem Gewissen?
Sonst dürfte man niemandem Geld
geben, der Drogen nimmt.
"Gassenzeitung"!
Da hat Andi recht: Auch wir dürfen
mit unserem verdienten Geld machen,
was wir wollen, auch wenn wir es
sprichwörtlich verpulvern.
Andi verkauft die restlichen
Exemplare der "Gassenzeitung",
und ich gehe zurück
in die Gassenküche.
In der Kontakt- und Anlaufstelle
verteilt Sandra Mura Kleider -
alles Spenden.
Niemand soll in zerlumpten Kleidern
herumlaufen müssen.
Auch das gehört
zur Würde des Menschen.
Orange?
- Nein, hallo! Diese ist geil.
Wer es nötig hat,
kann hier auch duschen
und sich einmal pro Monat
die Haare schneiden lassen.
Unten gibt es wie jeden Tag
das Mittagessen.
Aber plötzlich wird es hektisch:
ein Notfall.
Es gibt eine schwierige Situation,
weil jemand offenbar nicht
ansprechbar ist und nicht erwacht.
Sandra meint, vielleicht
müsse sie die Ambulanz rufen.
Hallo, hallo.
Alle sind recht angespannt, weil
niemand weiss, was er genommen hat.
Hörst du mich?
Hallo, Sandra,
ist das ein schwieriger Fall?
Ja, wir haben hier
eine Notfallsituation.
Das kommt bei uns nicht so oft vor.
Aber das ist ein Klient,
der zu Hause wahrscheinlich relativ
viele Medikamente geschluckt hat.
Dann kam er hierher
und die Wirkung setzte ein.
Seit gut 1 Std. überwachen wir ihn.
Wir messen seinen Blutdruck,
seinen Puls
und die Sauerstoffsättigung.
Wir müssen abschätzen,
ob wir besser
die Nr. 144 rufen sollen,
damit wir unsere Verantwortung
etwas abgeben können,
weil wir in 2 Std. schliessen.
Wir können ihn nicht hierbehalten
oder in ein Taxi setzen.
Es ist niemand, der sich
adäquat um ihn kümmern könnte.
Ich lasse dich ... - Ich muss
mich wieder um ihn kümmern.
Schliesslich entscheidet sich
Sandra, die Ambulanz zu rufen.
Kurze Zeit später
kommt der junge Mann
zum Glück wieder zu Bewusstsein.
Letzte Runde in der Gassenküche.
Ich sitze mit den Stammgästen
hinten im Hof, mit Andi und Otti.
Andi, würdest du dir
manchmal wünschen,
du hättest in deinem Leben
etwas anders gemacht? - Ja.
Ich würde mir wünschen,
ich hätte auf meinen Vater gehört
und studiert,
statt Heroin zu konsumieren.
Dann hätte ich die Firma übernommen.
Ja, das hätte ich anders gemacht.
- Ja.
Für mich stimmt es,
ich bereue nichts.
Selbst als ich noch drauf war,
arbeitete ich sechseinhalb Jahre
im Hotel hier vorne als Concierge.
Jeden Abend Chinesen einchecken
und machte den Abwasch.
Chinesen einchecken, das fehlt dir.
Wenn ich in fünf Jahren
wieder vorbeikommen würde,
würde ich euch ...
- Mich würdest du nicht antreffen.
Dich träfe ich in fünf Jahren
nicht mehr? - Zu 100 % Nein.
Warum? Wo wirst du dann sein?
In der Karibik.
Flipflops,
kurze Hosen und ein T-Shirt.
That's life.
Das war mein Abschlusswort.
Schön! Wir spielen
noch einen Sonnenuntergang ein.
Und Andi geht
in den Sonnenuntergang.
Noch geht Andi,
aber nicht in den Sonnenuntergang,
sondern nur
durch den Ausgang der Gassenküche,
die schliesst.
Auch im oberen Stock
wird aufgeräumt.
Ja, heute war
ein aussergewöhnlicher Tag.
Heute ist sehr viel gelaufen.
Wir sind froh, dass es 17 Uhr ist.
Jetzt machen wir Feierabend,
schliessen die Türen
und gehen nach Hause.
Sandra hat Dienstschluss,
für andere beginnt die Schicht erst:
Geld verdienen für den Stoff.
Ich traue mich nicht,
zu fragen, wohin sie geht.
Vielleicht möchte ich es
gar nicht so genau wissen.
(Frau) Auf Wiedersehen.
Die Sucht macht nie Feierabend.
Sandra und ihre Kolleginnen
sind morgen wieder hier.
Heilen können sie nicht,
aber einen Ort bieten,
der Menschen auffängt,
die am Fallen sind,
und ihnen gibt,
was jeder von uns braucht:
Menschlichkeit, Würde
und ein Stück Geborgenheit.
Vielen Dank, Sandra. Tschau!